these moldy car floors seats caked with
debris and crusty cup holders are in
need of a proper clean
we asked detailers to share the
filthiest cars they have ever worked on
they show us how a simple deep clean can
transform even the most forgotten
vehicles
to kick us off we'll follow Elizabeth
renovir of mo3 detailing
she shares how to make stained car
Interiors look brand new
foreign
[Music]
ER I am the owner and operator of mo3
detailing
[Music]
foreign
afterwards I put on a pre-treatment and
I let it sit for about 10 to 15 minutes
and then I agitate with the drill brush
or hard bristle brush
foreign
[Music]
so for the formats I like to hang them
up and rinse them out really well
because those can just be filled with
sand and dirt you know all that really
gets deep into the fireworks and just
vacuuming isn't enough
thank you
[Music]
next up Brent decheza from WD detailing
cleans the smelliest car he has ever
worked on my name is brenta cheser I'm
one half of WD detailing and today we're
going to be cleaning an extremely dirty
car that used to belong to a hoarder
who's now in treatment
when we first got this car we actually
had to leave it outside of our shop for
over a week just to let it air out
because it was one of the worst smelling
vehicles that we've ever been brought
only because there was so much Grime and
grease in both the carpets and the seats
and there was just a ton of garbage
everywhere
the first thing we did was use the ozone
machine the ozone machine removes air
pollutants and odors while also killing
bacteria and viruses inside the car
which makes it a lot safer for us to
work in there
after taking the seats out the first
thing that we do is take all the trash
out and completely vacuum the car that
way we can really see what we're working
with
so when you see a car in this condition
it doesn't always make too much sense to
save it but this car was brought to us
by a really really nice gentleman named
Parker he reached out to us and told us
that he wanted to clean the car and give
it away to someone who really needed it
that really touched us so we were
instantly in
as we were vacuuming we found a pile of
dead bugs that were just sitting on the
carpet right next to the back seat and
it was mixed in with some hair and just
some of the goodies when you're
detailing disaster cars
when people leave food or anything of
that sort that starts breaking down
that's when the maggots start appearing
in their cars they vacuum up pretty
easily as long as they don't splatter
all over the carpet but even then you
can just extract them this garbage was
so stuck on we literally could not get
it off with our hands even a power
washer isn't good enough to get it off
so we'll use a flathead screwdriver
occasionally that helps get stuff off of
the surface that we otherwise wouldn't
be able to
it actually wasn't sticky or oily it was
kind of like a rough feeling like Velcro
it's almost like that rough feeling
that's how how bad this carpet was if we
didn't pull the carpet out of this car
there was no possible way we were gonna
get it completely clean especially with
all the stains on it you would normally
want to replace this carpet but we were
trying to keep the budget as low as
possible as per Parker that's what he
wanted to do
so the original color of this car's
carpets floor mats seats was a gray and
when we got it they were almost black
the stains in the carpet came from I
don't even know honestly we were just
assuming that it's like grease and dirt
and everything mixed together
we have this carpet brush that will get
any hairs out of the carpet because this
carpet also had what seemed like dog
hair in it as well and we got all of
that out with a vacuum and our brush
we used a Degreaser instead of an
extractor soap only because Degreaser is
a bit stronger
and then we went ahead and drill brushed
it in to start getting it to work into
the fibers of the carpet
we ended up having a power wash and
extract this carpet four times
after you spend 20 minutes on the same
stain or half an hour and keep working
at it and
you can tell that it's not changing
color it's not coming out anymore and
there's really not that much more you
can do you know as a detailer it's kind
of time to just call it
I would say 85 of the stains and the
dirt were out of the carpet and about 15
that was just complete damage was never
going to come out
we hung it up inside of a closet where
there's a heater so we actually had to
let it dry for two days
so dying the carpet was actually a last
minute decision that I ended up making
myself the first step is to spray dye on
the carpet we use a brush to brush it
into the carpet to make sure it doesn't
just sit because if it sits then the
carpet will become like hard bristly
texture and then you'll go back and
you'll spray over it again and then you
just let it sit and dry and that's
really it the only things you want to be
careful about are inhaling the fumes so
we wore our respirators and because
we're in a parking garage we have a
really big exhaust fan right next to us
and we had that running the entire time
and we don't do this on normal carpets
or honestly ever but when we saw that
some of the stains weren't coming out we
wanted to make sure that this is going
to really change someone's life and
they're going to be happy when they
receive it
embedded in the seats are grease and
there were so much of it after we did
the entire extraction the first time we
let it dry overnight and we came back
the next day and it was completely
covered in grease again so everything
that was farther in the seat came to the
surface so we had to clean them a second
time so after we spray our extractor
soap we'll let the soap sit for about a
minute or two and then we'll go ahead
and use the drill brush to agitate the
soap into the fibers and then we'll
clean it up with the extractor
the extractor has a little nozzle that
sprays hot water into the fibers of the
seat and then it also has a vacuum head
so as it's spraying the water into it
it's sucking the water out at the same
time that way it can clean it we have a
clear head on it so we can actually see
all of the soap all of the dirt coming
out of the seat and when that water
coming through is completely clear
that's how you know when the seed is
clean
so now we're cleaning the back seat of
the car which was also one of the
grossest parts of the car and the first
thing we did was use a tornado to spray
off any of the dirt and that is simply
just an air compressor tool that shoots
out air in a tornado formation and
that'll get a lot of the dirt out of the
deeper fibers of the seat
and then after that we'll go on to the
extracting process
the tornado is best for getting any kind
of microparticles out of the carpet or
out of the seats and then Dust or dirt
or anything that's on like the topical
layer as well so at this point we're
taking apart the center console so we
can get it out of the car and pressure
wash all of the disgusting grease and
mold and everything off of it dirt
definitely gets behind both the radio or
any of the knobs on the center console
because that's where your hands are
touching a lot so by disassembling those
things and cleaning behind them we know
that we're sanitizing and doing the best
job that we possibly can
sometimes the tornador can't get things
that are super stuck on if they're gooey
or anything like that almost like a glue
substance to Plastics the air is not
going to do a good enough job so you
have to scrape it off on power washes
[Music]
we wanted to give it a good exterior
cleaning too it did have a thick layer
of dust on the exterior the engine bay
was dirty the wheels had brake dust all
over them
foreign
ly enough dirt or dust actually acts as
a protectant to paint so when a car is
Dusty or covered in a layer of dirt it
protects it from the Sun's UV rays
so the first thing that we do is we
spray our Degreaser all over the paint
because it's paint safe and that'll just
start loosening up any of the dirt on
the outside and then we'll use our power
washer to get the dirt off
[Music]
so after we wash the car we go ahead and
we spray the entire thing down with a
ceramic sealant while it's still wet and
that just gives it a little bit of
protection and also a shine after we
wash it and then we'll go ahead and
spray it down again before drying it
after we were done with it he actually
needed to take it back to his home shop
and do some mechanical work on it to
make sure it's safe for the people
whoever owns it next we're really happy
with the result of this car but what
meant the most to us is how Parker
reacted because this was something
special to him and the fact that we got
to be a part of it is why we did it in
the first place
we do all these details absolutely for
free so we took this on because we
wanted to make a change and we wanted to
help a family that needed it
foreign
for this car Brent tackles months of
mold growth caused by water damage
my name is Brent the cheser and I'm half
of WD detailing and today we're going to
be cleaning a super moldy car that has
grass growing in it mold water and all
of the above it was absolutely
disgusting
[Music]
first we put the ozone machine inside
the car it basically pumps oxygen to the
third degree into it or ozone and it
suffocates the bacteria and kills it and
then we'll pull the seats out after we
do the ozone treatment so we can
actually get to all the spots that we
need to and then the first thing that
we'll do is vacuum it try to get all the
debris or in this case the mold and the
water out of it so we can really get in
the car and work on it so here we're
working with where all the water ended
up going the water was only on half of
the car and I think that's because of
where the leak was located so what
you're looking at right now is US
vacuuming up all of that water
the last time that this car was plated
was in 2015 so ended up sitting for the
last six years and just about five
months ago the owner noticed that there
was an issue with the sunroof where it
wouldn't close all the way and water was
continuously getting in there but we've
never seen anything like this before
a car like this it's actually
recommended to remove the carpet throw
it away and replace it
but for some reason in this specific car
it was stapled down completely to the
point where if we were going to remove
it it wasn't going to go back in and sit
the way that it wouldn't need to for
this car it was definitely a different
process than when we would normally
extract a car because the carpet was
basically stained with that green mold
and we had to try to figure out a way to
push it out of the fibers of the carpet
and see if the carpet would revive to
the white color that it ended up being
so the first thing that we did which we
normally would not do is use the tornado
attachment which is compressed air that
shoots out in a circle like a tornado
almost you have like a little
compartment where you put all-purpose
cleaner in mixed with water so you
dilute it and you attach it to an air
hose on an air compressor and it really
gets into the fibers of that cloth and
kind of blows out anything that might be
in there so we blew out the entire
carpet with it after vacuuming it and
then we'll go ahead and we'll use our
extractor soap on it and spray like a
healthy amount on there and we'll
actually use the extractor which shoots
hot water into the carpet to get the
carpet a little bit more wet because
when we use our drill brush we want to
try to reduce the amount of friction
that we're putting into the carpet
because if there's too much friction if
it's not wet enough then it can actually
damage the carpet we'll use our drill
brush to agitate all of that soap so
we'll go over it a few times get it
really into the fibers and then we'll
use our hot water extractor which only
has water in it we don't ever recommend
putting any kind of soaps or anything in
your extractor because when you're
blowing the water into the carpet you
want to suck everything out and if you
have soap in it it's just going to add
more to it and it's not going to be
completely clean
I actually filled half of of shop back
full of water so I think I actually got
probably 95 to 99 of the water out
when you do the doors it's the same
thing as doing any of the other Plastics
in the car in this case we use tri-clean
which is made to kill bacteria and all
that stuff inside of cars While most
all-purpose cleaners do kill bacteria we
wanted something that is a Little Bit
Stronger especially because in this case
there's a lot more mold than you would
normally see in a regular car
and then use the tornado attachment or
some soft bristle brushes and really
getting every nook and cranny and make
sure we clean it up
so for this part he's actually drying
off the door and getting all the liquid
out of the nooks and crannies so that is
the torador attachment but that's a
different one than the one that is used
for specifically cleaning so This
Tornado attachment doesn't have the
canister that holds any kind of cleaner
and this one just blows out air so you
use that to get into cracks and crevices
where you normally couldn't with a brush
or with a microfiber towel or you use it
to get under seat
when we do leather seats that have been
sitting in mold the first thing we do
with NEC is vacuum it just to get any
kind of debris especially in the crevice
where the bottom and the back of the
seat meet will use an all-purpose
cleaner or a leather cleaner they're two
different things a leather cleaner is
more suitable for high-end leather and
then he'll spray it on there use a color
lock brush so it's like a really fine
strong brush to get into all of the
pores of the seat
when we're cleaning leather seats we
don't use too much pressure just because
you don't want to damage them you could
leave scratches you could tear them
spray it again use the steamer to kill
any bacteria and then wipe that away too
when we do the wheels the first thing we
like to do is pressure wash them off and
get any of that initial dirt or grime
off of them we have some heavy acid that
we'll use if it's really bad but we
don't use it on painted rims
and then we'll go ahead and we'll
agitate it with a brush and we'll use a
few different brushes to really get in
both the wheel well on the tire inside
the rim in the drum of the rim
and then we'll go ahead and pressure
wash it away
so for the exterior because it had been
sitting out for so long over time if you
don't clean it Grime will get attached
to the paint and start growing mold
because we did the exterior of the car
first we weren't too worried about water
getting in since it was already full of
water so we just went ahead and we
pressure washed everything out we put
paint safe Degreaser all over the paint
because it just had a really thick layer
of both mold and Grime on it that
wouldn't just come off with an initial
pressure wash we let it sit for about
two to three minutes and then we
pressure washed it again and then we'll
go ahead and we'll use the foam Cannon
so the foam is just a car soap and you
just put it into a foam Cannon and you
attach it to your pressure washer it
acts as a lubricant for any dirt that's
on the car so when you go to wash it
you're really minimizing how much
scratching can happen to the paint
and then we'll go ahead and we'll use
our microfiber mitts to wash it and then
spray it off
the absolute best way to store a car if
it's going to be outside is with some
sort of car cover or a tarp that way no
water is going to get on the top of the
car and find its way into the car it'll
keep the Paint clean and away from all
the elements if it's going to be a car
that you're not driving for extended
periods of time you still want to look
in it and make sure nothing's going
wrong because seals can give and if they
do and water starts getting in then
that's a whole world a problem so the
best way to stop mold is to be proactive
and check on your car before it actually
starts growing
when it comes to detailing I believe
it's best to maybe get a full detail
once to twice a year maybe three times I
always tell people to vacuum it if not
every few weeks at least once a month
RJ Wagner from WD detailing now attempts
to revive this unusually muddy car I'm
RJ I'm one half of WD detailing and
today we're going to be showing you how
we clean quite possibly the muddiest WS6
Firebird ever it was involved in a
really bad flood in Kentucky the car was
absolutely covered basically head to toe
and caked on mud to the point to where
the mud had dried and it was starting to
crack almost like a desert floor
rock hard I can only assume that it was
involved in very fast moving water it
picked up sediment from somewhere nearby
and then it dried out
so the first step is removing pretty
much anything except for the dashboard
and the steering wheel and the steering
column because that was a little bit
more involved than we really had time
for
using the vacuum to remove any residual
water in the back of the trunk
going into the detail I knew a lot of
this vehicle was going to be sold for
parts because there was only x amount
made and only a certain amount of parts
available it wouldn't make sense to
scrap that car especially with so many
parts still being functional the change
some of the ways that we were going to
be cleaning the vehicle and using some
methods that we wouldn't use in a normal
detail and we've never done this before
but we literally took a pressure washer
and sprayed out the whole interior of
the vehicle in order to remove all the
mud so the reason why we wouldn't do
that in a normal detail job is it would
definitely damage some of the electrical
components of the vehicle if you didn't
give the car ample time to dry so if
this was a normal vehicle that we did
that in we would have to disconnect the
battery and then make sure that it dried
out for over five or six days
with a car in this condition to clean
the carpet was again different than most
vehicles that we see on a daily basis so
we probably spent about 45 minutes just
pressure washing gallons of water into
the carpet in order to try and flush as
much mud out of it as possible
well not only that we had to flip it
over and spray out mud on the other side
and then we actually had to let it drain
overnight to try and dry out as much as
we could before we put it back in the
next day to then continue to clean it
inside the car so once the carpet's dry
we then place it back into the vehicle
and we use carpet soap you spray it onto
the carpet and then actually use the
extractor to add more water in order to
create a soapier solution and then you
agitate it using a brush that connects
to a drill to release some of the dirt
and grime or the stains that are
contained within the carpet fibers bring
them to the top so then you can suck it
away with the extractor
in the extractor we only use water if
you spray the soap onto the carpet and
if you only have water in your extractor
when you see through the head of the
extractor that there's no more foam
there's no more bubbles or soap that's
coming out of the carpet you know you've
not only removed the contaminants that
were in the carpet but also any residue
from a leftover soap
when we were cleaning the leather we had
the pressure wash the majority of the
mud away first in order to even reveal
the leather to follow a normal type of
detailing method there's too much mud on
the surface to really remove it in any
other way so that's not typically how we
would clean leather seats but drastic
cases call for drastic measures we then
used an all-purpose cleaner in a
tornador that's basically compressed air
that feeds into a reservoir that holds
an all-purpose cleaner and then it uses
that compressed air to pick up the
solution and blast it into the material
that you're trying to clean we'll use it
when we know that the leather has seen a
lot of age and we don't want to
potentially damage it further and then I
went ahead and used a leather brush in
order to agitate that further to remove
as much mud and sediment as possible
these would have to drive for another
couple days in a heated storage facility
with the exterior we went ahead and just
did a pretty basic wash so we had to
make sure that we just blew out all the
mud from all the cracks and crevices
there the foam Cannon is my personal
favorite part when it comes to washing
the exterior of a vehicle foam and soap
is the same thing it's actually like
shaving cream you spray it onto your
hand and as you lather it up it becomes
more foamy it helps break down some of
the grime the grease the sediment on the
vehicle and then lifts it to the top and
that way as you're washing there's both
lubrication as well as cleaning
properties that help you remove the dirt
and grime as efficiently and safely as
possible cleaning the windows most
people ask what solution you're using
what window cleaner are you using but in
reality it's the the type of towel that
you use and how many towels you use and
how clean they are so windows are very
prone to streaking especially when
they've been splattered with mud like
they were in this vehicle so to start
out we just use your standard shop
towels in order to remove the bulk of
the grime and then we use no other type
of towel that's called GSM so it has a
higher grams per square meter of
microfiber and all that means is that
there's more fibers on the towel and the
more grams per square meter the fluffier
the towel and the more microfiber
strands there are to wipe away any of
the streaks
they actually were able to get that car
running again though it still functions
but with a good conscious they can't
sell that car to another owner
when you finish it and you look back at
the result you know we we laugh because
it's it's almost like I don't know how
this I don't know how it came out so
well but somehow it does
foreign
this abandoned car has layers of debris
after sitting in a barn for 37 years
my name is Brent duchesser I'm one half
of WD detailing and today we're going to
be cleaning a 1978 Sterling Nova that
sat in a barn since 1985.
so Sterling Nova is a kit car which is
on a Volkswagen Beetle chassis and
engine and it's really unique because of
the way it looks and the way that the
top opens
there's no doors on this car the way
that you get in and out is literally by
the whole top lifting up we had to take
the top off of this car because it
actually couldn't hold its own weight up
and we didn't want to risk it falling on
one of us as soon as we took the top off
of the car we found this mouse Nest
right on the back side of the dash
it was made out of insulation or carpet
or parts from the seats any random
fibers that they can find in the car
they'll take and make a nest out of then
we sanitize the area afterwards with
triclean which is a cleaner that will
kill all the bacteria
cars attract mice because they know that
it's a dark space and when these cars
sit in a barn and nobody's touching them
for 30 plus 40 plus years they're not
going to be bothered so they're gonna
take advantage of that and then after
that we were able to take the seats out
and really get in there and clean
everything we found that these carpets
were completely disintegrated and
they're definitely going to have to
replace them and we actually haven't
really seen carpets this bad before so
if I had to make an assumption on why
this happened It's a combination of them
sitting over time and the mice getting
into them and eating them up and under
the carpet as soon as we pulled it out I
looked down and found a nice surprise of
a dead mouse
we disposed of it off camera but we just
had to pick it up with our gloves and
toss it in the garbage can
there's no nice way to throw away a dead
mouse
we started vacuuming the floor pans and
then we sanitized them again with our
tri-clean
and then we used our steamer behind it
to kill anything else
and then we wiped it all away with
microfiber towels
so this dashboard was covered in dust
completely and at this point we're still
using triclean to clean the interior
because we want to disinfect everything
we knew that this car isn't going to be
started for quite a while because it
doesn't run and it needs a lot of repair
work so if cleaner gets inside the
buttons or inside of the switches it's
not going to be the end of the world
because it'll definitely be running
through this car
[Music]
so if you want to get a barn find a good
way is searching on Facebook Marketplace
the people that we work with
specifically search for these cars and
then they bring them to us because they
sat for so long a lot of it's Word of
Mouth
so for these seats they were covered in
anything that the mice could put on them
so the first thing that we do is vacuum
them and then we'll go ahead and extract
them so we use our extractor soap and
then we'll use our drill brush to
agitate the soap and really work it into
those fibers and then we'll use our
extractor which shoots hot water into
the fibers and also sucks it away at the
same time so it's a vacuum but it's a
vacuum with water
the exterior of this car was covered in
dust from front to back and then there
was some wood chips and other stuff in
the headlight crevice which I'm pretty
sure on this kit they're supposed to be
a headlight cover but for some reason
they were missing on this specific car
and here we're vacuuming out some of the
jams which we like to do before we
pressure wash off the car because if
there's any wood chips or anything it
might scratch the paint
so on the wheels they were covered with
some sort of green substance which I
don't know if it was mold or not and to
clean this tire we'll go ahead and
pressure wash everything off of it first
and then we'll use our pns brake Buster
on the tire and the rim and then we'll
use an assortment of brushes usually
soft bristle brushes and a tire brush
and then we'll pressure wash it all away
the paint on this car was in pretty good
condition the only thing that we noticed
was deteriorating was the black paint so
we're spraying on this car is a paint
safe Degreaser so we can loosen up all
that dirt before we pressure wash it
away and what that's going to do is
minimize any kind of swirl marks or
scratches
paint chips can be damaging to a car
only because it can cause rust to form
if there's metal underneath where the
paint was but there was no rust on this
body at all because it's made out of
fiberglass
so we're starting to film the car here
using our pressure washer and foam
Cannon and this is the part that a lot
of people find the most satisfying in
the whole process and there's two
reasons why people use foam cannons the
first one is as a pre-soak so they can
loosen up all the dirt that's on the
surface of the car but also instead of
just putting soap in a bucket it helps
you put soap over the entire car which
makes the process safer for the paint
and easier
foreign
the car we'll use microfiber mitts on
the entire car to wash it down
and now we're using our rupez buffer to
take any of the oxidation off the top
layer of the paint which will make it a
lot shinier less dull and give it that
overall wow factor at the end so this is
just like a paint correction when it
came to the black paint we didn't even
polish it at all because it was starting
to come off of the car and we didn't
want to ruin or take away any of that
paint that was already there
there wasn't too much that we could
personally do it's something that would
have to either be redone or just left as
is
and after the whole car is cleaned and
we're ready to do the finishing touches
we'll do a tire shine and as that dries
it leaves the tires looking nice and
matte black and it just gives it that
overall wow factor for the customer and
the absolute last thing we'll do is
spray a ceramic sealant over the entire
car it'll protect the paint just a
little bit but it also give it a nice
shine and just complete the detail and
that's it
I was super happy with the way that this
car turned out I actually personally
want to buy it myself we'll see how that
goes in the near future when it's done
being fixed up
when it comes to cleaning barn finds if
I can give any advice it's just to take
your time and really do your research
that way you don't make any super
detrimental mistakes because the last
thing you want to do is find something
that has original paint or an original
interior and damage it but also have fun
with the process
foreign
next up this car has seen better days as
22 years of mold is deep cleaned
hi my name is brenta cheser I'm one half
of WD detailing and today we're going to
be cleaning a really moldy Buick Riata
that's sat outside for over 22 years
the owner took me into his backyard and
as soon as I saw this one specifically I
knew we had to do it when we opened the
doors the first thing that we found was
a ton of mold and what looks like a
mouse Nest beginning to form at some
point
all in all this car smelled absolutely
horrendous and it was just disgusting
so the first thing that we're doing is
working on the engine bay and that means
getting rid of all of the leaves and
anything that piled up over the years in
the jam of the bay after that we went
ahead and we used a pressure washer and
some Degreaser on it and after we
finished the engine bay we moved on to
the wheels so when cleaning the wheels
the first thing we'll do is pressure
wash them off just to get a cleaner
surface
and then we'll spray our Wheel and Tire
cleaner on them and use a couple
different brushes to get into the wheel
crevices and on the face of the rim and
then behind the rim and in the barrel
and after that we'll spray everything
away leaving a really clean wheel
now we're getting ready to pressure wash
and clean the outside of the car we
wanted to use our paint safe Degreaser
first to loosen up all that mold and
grime before we actually took a pressure
washer to the surface and then we
started pressure washing which is by far
the most satisfying part of any detail
that we do
so our process with pressure washing we
always like to try to work from top to
bottom so the first thing we did was the
roof so we went to the hood after that
and then the sides
and then the rear
just watching the pressure washer go in
straight lines taking away those years
of grime just feels so good inside I
can't even explain it
and after having all that pressure
washed off we'll go ahead and spray the
entire car down with our foam Cannon
so here we're using the foam Cannon and
the reason for that is because after
pressure washing the car there is still
Grime and dirt left on the surface of
the paint and the foam Cannon really
just helps add more soap to the paint
than putting soap in a bucket wood and
when you're washing the car off with
microfiber mitts it makes it easier to
do and quicker
after we wash it off we spray the
Ceramic spray just to give it some
protection before moving onto the
interior
foreign
so in our first round of vacuuming we
knew that this car was really bad so we
weren't going to get everything so we
definitely were going to need to use the
drill brush and extractor later on
this area looks like mice made a nest
and they were both leaving their
droppings behind and also bringing some
food or different materials from the
inside of the car that they could find
we were able to vacuum that up and
actually get it pretty clean so when we
work on doors that have leather or vinyl
or anything like that we're pretty much
using the same process especially when
they're covered in mold the first thing
we'll do is use tri-clean which is a
cleaner that kills 99.9 percent of
bacteria and then we'll use soft bristle
brushes and sometimes a steamer from a
distance just to kill the bacteria and
kill the mold and then we'll wipe it
away and we'll spend a decent amount of
time on each section of the car to make
sure that we really get it clean before
moving on to the next one we repeat the
process with the steamer and the
tri-clean throughout the entire interior
including the steering wheel which was
covered in a very thick layer of old
worse than any steering wheel we've ever
seen
so what we're using is the tornador and
that's pressurized air and it's using it
to dry it off and also blow out any
product that could be in the cracks or
anything like that older leather can
definitely be tougher to work with
because if mold sits on it for a long
time it can damage it it can remove the
dye and you also have to be really
careful with the steamer because if you
spend too much time in one area or you
get too close it can definitely damage
it
and after we clean the interior
components we'll go ahead and focus on
the carpets the first thing we'll do is
spray our extractor soap into the carpet
and we'll get it wet and then we'll use
the drill brush to agitate it into the
fibers of the carpet to help release any
stains or any dirt that's in there
and then we'll use the extractor to suck
that all away
and after the interior is completely
clean with the leather and the vinyl
anything like that we'll go ahead and
use a leather conditioner that way it
can bring back the softness and the
suppleness but it also leaves it with a
nice shine
[Music]
and then some of the final things that
we do to the car is cleaning the windows
and we add a tire shine to give the car
those finishing touches so when the
owner actually sees it it gives that wow
factor all in all this detail probably
took us around 12 hours over the course
of one day and just looking over the
final results of the car we couldn't
have been happier with the way it turned
out even though there was some damage to
the exterior with the paint everything
else absolutely was fantastic
thank you
Andreas Urich from Workshop rebuild
shares how he uses a laser to remove
years of rust from this old car
hi my name is Andreas yurich on social
media I go by Workshop rebuild and today
I'll be sharing with you guys the laser
cleaning process and I'll be cleaning 40
Years of rust on a classic Renault car
from 1979. laser cleaning is a process
where a laser beam gets emitted from a
laser cleaning machine and this handheld
device will always be pointed towards a
metal surface with any surface
contaminants if you have parts that come
in that are just full of grease full of
oil just full of any surface
contamination you can actually use this
laser cleaning process to remove all of
that
looking at the Renault R5 Le Car the
Bodywork is still very straight but
around the edges it does have some Rust
and especially on the underside or
around the wheel wells you will see
quite a bit of rust and I would like to
remove that so I can bring this car back
to running conditions and also make it
somehow suitable for the road the first
step is just really visually looking at
everything it's really important to know
where the rust is building up and which
direction it's going in to actually
address it with the laser cleaner the
next step is actually just to prepare
the laser cleaning machine once I have
all the settings set up I will put on my
protective gear so I will be wearing a
mask and I will be wearing laser
protective glasses just to be safe after
that I grabbed the handheld gun and I
get to work and I started off with the
wheels I'm taking away quite a bit of
rust and that's been built up for over
40 years right so the most outer parts
of the car I wanted to clean first and I
was going to work my way in that was
just my thought process can be in any
other order but that's just the way I do
things after the wheels were cleaned I
did the fenders themselves right around
the fenders at rusts because you have
all the time water splashing up on the
fender and that's where it will Rust
because the water actually doesn't
evaporate or go away
[Music]
once I was done with the fenders I moved
into the wheel hubs
they cleaned up the rust very well I was
really surprised that it cleaned up
everything
cleaned up the threads on the hubs
themselves
[Music]
so how does laser cleaning actually work
so the laser cleaning machine has a
certain frequency once its frequency is
established within the Laser Source that
will be emitted through the handheld gun
once it's pointed at your work piece it
will resonate with the contamination on
top of the metal surface the metal
surface is the last resort that will not
absorb any light so everything above the
metal surface will actually absorb the
light of the laser cleaning machine once
it touches anything above the metal the
heat will actually remove the
contamination on top of the metal either
than that if it's not the pressure of
the heat the laser beam itself will
vaporize the substance on top right so
it's either or right and that happens
within milliseconds nanoseconds so with
any laser cleaning machine this is a
beam of light and it also creates a lot
of heat you can damage the surface
substrate which is the metal so you
always want to keep your tool or your
handheld gun in motion you do not want
to keep it too long at one certain area
or on one spot because you can damage
the metal if you keep it on one spot for
too long
once I finished up with wheel hubs I
actually moved on to the muffler that
was on the other side there are exactly
four settings on this machine that I can
manipulate so the first setting is power
the second setting is frequency the
third setting is the speed of the laser
beam itself and the fourth setting is
the width of the laser beam so with all
these settings I can vary or adjust the
laser beam so if I'm cleaning aluminum I
will bring the settings a little bit
down because aluminum is softer and it
also has a lower melting temperature
for steel I go up in the settings and
usually I run them at around 80 percent
and aluminum I run at 60 percent
I really noticed along the body panels I
have to be very delicate I had to bring
down the values a little bit because
that metal is so thin I just had to keep
it in movement all the time
and lastly I ended up around the engine
where some components were already
missing but I obviously cleaned up the
inside of the engine so you can see the
before and after on all four cylinders
the cylinders cleaned up very well
the cylinder head the intake manifold
and the exhaust manifold were removed
from the car previously so I could clean
them up on the bench and cleaning them
up on the bench actually gives me the
opportunity to clean them all the way
around which makes it super easy and the
final finish also shows that it's a much
better way to clean them on the bench
what's really nice about it is that you
do not damage the substrate which is the
metal surface so if you're working on
machined areas like internal components
for an engine anything around any
Bodywork for a very very delicate
restoration project or even something
historical you do not want to damage
that substrate so that's where laser
cleaning comes in
so the technology behind laser cleaning
is evolving very fast a lot of companies
or manufacturers are starting to hook
these up to robots and to their
production lines even after something is
manufactured in any industry there is
still some residue debris or something
that has to be removed for a further
process so when I look at the final
result of this car from front to back or
outside to in I'm really happy and
satisfied with the finish the body
panels clean up very well and removed
all the paint and removed all the primer
it even removed some of the rust that
was actually even chipping away and
towards the front of the engine where I
have aluminum parts it just cleaned that
perfect without any issues and without
any thermal damage I was really happy
with everything and now I can continue
on with my rebuild process since this
technology is really new I'm still
learning as I'm going so uh I don't I'm
not a true professional just yet but I'm
learning every day I'm really into this
new technology and I can't wait for this
technology to get better in the near
future
[Music]
dry snation takes it one step further
with the latest detailing technology
dry ice
Scott Ailes with dry ice Nation so today
I'd like to show you the step-by-step
process that we go through in dry ice
cleaning
so there's a number of things that are
unique about dry ice cleaning number one
we're not using water
so when we're done we're not cleaning up
water spots and we're not trying to dry
things if you can see the dirt we can
clean it so there's a lot of places
where you might be able to see that dirt
but you can't physically get to it with
any tools or brushes or devices and you
know we can we can clean that in the
Deep recesses of your car that you might
not have been able to before it's like
when the car rolled off the factory line
you've cleaned it back to that condition
so what we're just getting started we're
trying to identify the method of what
we're going to attack first when we put
a car in the lift we always want to make
sure and pull the wheels off so we can
inspect the inner wheel house area we
use a torque wrench to break the lug
nuts loose we also like to consider
depending on the customer if they want
us to remove the inner wheelhouse liners
which are typically plastic to see if
they want us to clean behind there
so once we have the car on the lift and
we're prepped we're we're then moving
our attention toward the compressed air
system to make sure that we've got all
of our drying and cleaning systems for
the air system in order and then we're
going to load the machine with the dry
ice so that we're prepared to blast
and so the first thing we try to do is
get the wheels out of the way we have
four wheels and we'll just take those
one at a time
yeah we'll look for tar we'll look for
adhesion uh remnants from old wheel
weights which are totally a pain to
remove and we make that pretty easy and
then we just we'll clean the wheels
inside and out
[Music]
the three settings are you've got
pressure which is PSI that you're all
familiar with there's pounds per minute
and then you've got size of particle so
those are the three things that you can
adjust but for the first time we can
actually choose the size of the particle
so it enables us to be able to do
delicate things in the same area of
things that might be aggressive
previously you were putting those
delicate items at risk but the large
particle size
when we're starting the project we're
always looking for the dirtiest area
first we like to get the hard stuff out
of the way so that we get to those
surfaces or those Coatings that we're
trying to remove that are easy then it
makes everything go smoother because
you're not double cleaning so you'll
notice as I'm cleaning that the gun is
never static it's always moving it's
always constantly moving and the reason
for that is we have the risk of a
concentrated 109 negative degrees on a
particular substrate or part of the car
that you could damage in one spot
so I'd like to take a minute and explain
how this actually works there's really
three things that are occurring you've
got kinetic energy which is driven by
the PSI of the air system you've got
cold temperature 109 degree negative
that causes things to shrink so they
lose adhesion and then you've got the
actual thermal expansion of a solid
chemical going to a gas so that's 800
times its original solid size those
three things work very well together to
remove this dirt in a way that you
probably never seen before
there's a lot of technique opportunity
here right because in a sense this is
this is a bit of a an artist's effort at
an industrial job if you will I've found
it to be helpful for me to function in a
circular pattern so that I never have
any hard lines the circular pattern
gives me the control that I feel
comfortable with
there's really nothing that's more fun
in this process than doing bare aluminum
you really can't hurt bare aluminum and
so in that case you can crank it up it's
more efficient you feel better about it
and and it's it's very satisfying to the
eye
so once we've removed those really
difficult grimy uh surfaces uh we we do
move into a combination of hand work and
fine detail dry ice cleaning people
presume that what we're doing is a magic
wand and we just wave it once and we're
done and that's not true
when we have surface rust we do
integrate a fair amount of hand work
whether it be all-purpose Cleaners White
erasers osfo pour out steel wool
definitely we we do use handwork at the
point in time that we we believe we're
finished with the underside we'll bring
the car down three or four feet and then
we'll look at the top of the suspension
in the Wheelhouse areas and then we'll
notice okay we've got some more work to
do here so once we've cleaned the
underside of the car we bring the car
down on the lift and we have an extra
wide lift so that we can open the doors
get the floor mats out we can do the
interior vents the door jambs the engine
bay the trim and and we don't abrade the
surface and we'll do what takes somebody
two hours in 10 minutes
[Music]
so we were fortunate enough to receive
this 55 Porsche Speedster and it
literally is a barn find what you're
seeing here is me trying to see if I can
remove this crazy thick mold that's 30
40 years old off 60 year old vinyl
that mold was so thick it would stop
your fingernail this was a big moment
for us and the end result is we will
apply some all-purpose cleaner at the
end and we'll wipe off the final film
from this panel but it just turns out
spectacular
so we don't add to or remove any CO2
from the environment so we're neutral
and we don't use water which means that
we don't rinse chemicals down a drain
into any cyst sewer systems or into
drain Fields so from an environmental
standpoint by far it is absolutely a
better cleaning solution than using
water and chemicals
the driest cleaning world could be
considered the highest level OCD crowd
think about the underside of a car in
the intricacies of every component
there's a lot of surface area to all of
these parts and pieces don't think that
it's going to be easy but the
satisfaction factor for those that care
about the way their assets or their
artifacts look is at the highest level
so it's it's worth the energy
gave Tyler from GT detailing takes us
behind the scenes of Reviving this cough
filled with trash the details started by
removing the stained seats and formats
Gabe evaluates whether the seats need to
be removed depending on any stains under
the seat and between the center console
once the floor was exposed Gabe
separated the trash and customers
personal belongings using his hand to
remove the bigger items and a vacuum to
clean up any leftover trash
he cleaned the door jams with the
Degreaser and brush followed by a power
washer to remove any dirt or gunk
this step is done early in the detailing
process and before shampooing in case
water sprays on the carpet
a vacuum removed as much dirt and junk
as possible from around the car
including the floor seats and under the
spare tire cover
after vacuuming Gabe started as the
chemical cleaning process working from
the top down to avoid double cleaning
due to chemicals and soap dripping down
to remove stains on the headliner he
used a spray drill brush and microfiber
towel
he deep cleaned the floor mats with the
pressure washer and shampoo and then
hung them to dry
to restore the seats Gabe used a steam
cleaner dry brush and extractor to
remove any stains he prefers to use
McCulloch Steamers because there are
multiple attachments to choose from
moving to the carpet Gabe sprayed a
carpet cleaner and used an agitator to
bring any hidden dirt to the surface
sucking it up with a mighty extractor
he steam cleaned the steering wheel and
pedals with the brush attachment
steam cleaners help remount dried melted
Gunk like candy and chocolate for an
easier removal
he treated the door panels with a vacuum
spray steam cleaner and microfiber towel
for plastic surfaces Gabe works and
small sections to ensure he doesn't miss
any spots
once the plastic surfaces were clean he
applied a plastic UV protector
Gabriel stalled the seats and floor mats
into the car and cleaned the glass and
the detailing was complete
Larry casilla shares the importance of
keeping your car clean and how to
prevent water damage from leaks hey I'm
Larry casilla from monyc.com we
manufacture car cleaning supplies today
I'm going to show you the step-by-step
process for cleaning one of the most
disgusting cars I've ever worked on
right off the bat I'm saying there's a
water leak somewhere there's obviously
mice this particular case it smelled so
bad there's urine from mice in there
this is kind of the next level where
you're cleaning it just to make it so
that you can safely operate the vehicle
on cases like this one there's lots of
mold lots of junk I increase the water
temperature as much as the power washer
can handle and that'll increase the
cleaning ability when you hit it with
water it's going to indicate where there
might be a leak there's seals what they
call rails or rain guards or rain rails
if those get packed or compacted with
you can see in the door jambs muck and
Gunk and grime and leaves it actually
backs up and overflows and then flows
into the vehicle
the debris in the door jambs were 100
the cause uh for the water basically the
water pools on the bottom underneath the
carpet I use a tiny little brush to kind
of get in there the idea is to lift a
lot of the door Steels and get
underneath the door seals because if
they're not perfectly flush again that
whole rain issue as the door closes and
if there's leaves and junk in there it
just won't seal properly
so in terms of buffing or restoring the
paint this mission was to use a
microfiber cutting pad I used a compound
and with that microfiber pad does is it
kind of tickles the surface of the paint
so to speak and it removes a lot of the
stuff that just didn't come out with a
wash and if it's embedded in the pores
of the paint just like a blackhead so to
speak I have to go in there and just
remove all that exfoliated
but as the the vibration or what we call
oscillation of the machine this is as
it's buzzing it's actually vibrating a
lot of the dirt that's behind the the
headlights and the tail lights and all
these little pieces so in this case I
washed the car for a second time uh
after I buffed it then afterwards you
want to protect it again so in this case
we use a product called ammo reflex Pro
which is a type of coating it's an
anti-microbial which is perfect for this
car because obviously there's mold and
bacteria all over the place
when it comes to headlights as the sun
is penetrating the headlight it's just
chewing up all the UV protection it has
and over time it sort of just decays
right it becomes dead skin on top so
what we need to do is remove that dead
skin then you can go in just like the
paint with a microfiber cutting pad an
abrasive like a compound use your pad
polish stuff you can see within a minute
or two it'll rejuvenate that now you
have to put the suntan lotion on and in
this case you want to re-clear coat it
with respect to Windows the best way
that I found over the years and this is
an evolving process is first you use a
little bit of window cleaner you spray
it down first thing is use a scrub pad
that scrub pad is going to lift a lot of
the oils and chunk that are stuck to the
glass over time and so as you do that
it's still going to be wet and kind of
gross you take what we call towel number
one and you scoop up all of that oily
residue it's not going to look pretty at
that at this point and that's totally
fine so once it's kind of dry then you
go back in lubricate again with a glass
cleaner and then use a squeegee working
top to bottom for obvious reasons then
you go in with a separate towel I'll
call number two towel and you can wipe
it down sometimes they call them glass
towels then you can really go in and
buff the edges so it's this constant
running after smears
when we're vacuuming the inside of the
car first thing you want to look at is
the size of the debris that you're
trying to vacuum up and then first thing
is sort of uh vacuum up the big parts
then I put in what's called a crevice
tool a crevice tool sort of looks like
your hand it's very narrow you remove a
lot more debris that way because the
orifice is much smaller thus the the
lifting power is much better
with respect to shampooing you can use a
scrub a red handle scrub brush under two
dollars or whatever they're everywhere
in this case we use ammo shag which is a
cleaner just for Fibers carpets
Alcantara seats that kind of thing and
then the goal is to agitate the junk to
the surface and then Wet Vac it out I
thought I had already sucked up a lot of
the poo and all that stuff but as I was
shampooing you could actually see little
bits of mouse poo in the shampoo machine
which is insane that means Mouse Poop
was not only on top of the surface but
underneath
so when you remove certain parts of the
vehicle like carpets or the rear trunks
uh you can pull that out and shampoo it
that's way better because this just
compressed water shooting out all the
junk it's way better than just sitting
there and going back and forth but it
makes sense you can't do that to let's
say that the carpets underneath the
seats you're not going to do that
okay so to clean the interior we use a
couple of different tools uh use ammo
lather that is designed for plastic
leather and vinyl and then we use an
interior scrub brush it's really good
for buttons and things and then we use a
scrub pad now the scrub pad basically
takes that top layer of junk off before
you come in with a microfiber towel then
once you're all done and you're
scrubbing because what you're doing is
you're agitating the dirt it comes to
the surface what we call a lather and
then you scoop away that that junk once
everything is done you take compressed
air blow them out and as the lather sort
of squeaks out from underneath on the
sides and just scoop it up with a
microfiber towel let it dry assess the
situation then you can go back in any
spots you missed
the separation between a regular detail
and an amazing detail is usually the
last like three four five percent so you
have silver from the car and then you
have this kind of faded whitish gross
you know material or trim you want to
you want to brighten that up so I took
the the pad and applied mud and again
it's to draw this contrast
even if you're not a car person even if
you're not excited about washing your
car there is a level of cleanliness that
actually translates into Dollars into
saving your investment in this case
you have to keep those those seals clean
at the very minimum especially if you
park outside
[Music]